c'est que je peux vous dire à mon sens
c'est que le président Macron se soucie
de l'avenir de la France et c'est un
homme intelligent il sait ce qui est
important
en tout cas il fait tout ce qu'il peut
pour ce pays
et je suis un fan du président moi-même
alors je sais que tout le monde ne
l'aime pas autant mais moi je l'aime
bien
il a aussi bon vous savez il a racheté
Twitter il y a beaucoup de critiques à
propos de la liberté d'expression sur
Twitter on en a parlé ici souvent
beaucoup du reposent d'être trop laxiste
d'avoir réactivé les comptes de
personnes jugées antisémites ou racistes
ou homophobes regardez ce qu'il dit
c'est la modération est réalisée par à
peu près 4000 collaborateurs qui
travaillent là-dessus tout ce qui est
discours de haine on diminué de 20 à 40%
depuis l'acquisition c'est parce que
disent les différentes enquêtes qui ont
été menées c'est plutôt le contraire en
fait c'est une explosion de ces de ces
discours là qui a été qui a été relevé
vous-même vous n'avez pas constaté non
non je persiste à dire qu'il y en a
moins
d'avoir une définition très élargie du
message de haine
mais il faut éviter d'avoir une
définition trop large car si tout
devient un message de haine évidemment
on ne peut plus rien juger ou alors il
faut tout censurer mais ça ça bloquera
complètement la liberté d'expression
c'était très dur dans les questions lui
il jouait le jeu et répondait il
souriait à chaque fois il voulait le
casser sur Twitter sur les messages de
haine c'est pas non plus le seul
responsable de l'année sur Twitter donc
il faut avoir un minimum de respect pour
lui et c'est non non il était pour la
liberté d'expression mais on peut pas le
lui a promis la responsabilité de tous
les messages de Twitter américain et les
Américains c'est vraiment ils sont
habitués parce que c'est une façon
d'interviewer très anglo-saxonne et ils
sont ça ils sont très habitués à ce
qu'on leur rentre dedans etc c'est
l'inverse qu'il aurait surpris je pense
moi il m'a choqué dans ses propos et là
notamment quand il dit faut pas avoir
une définition trop large des messages
de haine c'est antisémite ou ça ne l'est
pas on peut pas jouer avec ça et là je
trouve qu'il laisse la porte ouverte à
des messages qui se propage sur Twitter
parce qu'il ne contrôle pas et parce
qu'il ne moderne pas donc moi je trouve
que c'est dangereux sa politique voilà
moi il me fait il me fait plutôt peur
parce que je trouve que que ce genre de
personnage qui sont richissime qui ont
un pouvoir pas possible j'ai
l'impression qu'ils prennent le pas sur
les gouvernements là il se permet de de
juger Macron alors voilà on dirait que
c'est le login c'est le boss de Macron
quoi quand il parle donc moi c'est ce
genre de personnage je trouve que c'est
inquiétant parce qu'on a l'impression
que c'est eux qui tirent les mallettes
et ça et moi ça ça me fait peur les
manettes alors je le savais vous l'avez
dit tu vois il est tellement puissant
qu'il accueilli partout comme un chef
d'État elle lui a demandé du coup si ça
lui dirait d'être président des
États-Unis et il dit il y a qu'une seule
chose que le président peut faire de
plus que lui regardez est-ce que vous
aimeriez un jour être président de la
République aux États-Unis non non j'ai
pas envie pourquoi
vous savez les gens imaginent quelques
fois que le président des États-Unis et
dans un poste extrêmement puissant alors
oui d'une certaine façon bien sûr
américaine est-elle que le poste de
président et dans une position très
limitée en fait vous êtes en train de me
dire que vous êtes plus puissant que le
président des États-Unis
alors disons que je ne peux pas déclarer
la guerre et que la liberté d'action
d'un président des États-Unis est
extrêmement limitée si j'étais président
je ne pourrais pas par exemple envoyer
des fusées sur la lune ou sur Mars
envoyer des gens vivre là-bas à créer
des véhicules électriques durables
il a raison il a raison je suis désolé
mec voilà merci
dangereux moi je trouve qu'il est
dangereux non mais c'est parce que oui
ok il est génial
je comprends pas pourquoi vous le
trouvez dangereux moi j'aime ces gens-là
qui voient plus haut plus fort
c'est bien d'être de réinjecter dans
Twitter des propos antisémites racistes
sexistes et homophones
la vision de l'espace la vision des
voitures
de l'industrie comme ça qui est un sort
de de de fou
rire ça génial
son génie contrairement à ce que tu
penses au service des gens il est son
service de lui dire
combien de personnes
contre les règlements contre les
syndicats c'est vrai que tout le monde
n'est pas la bière merci très bonne très
bonne réponse de bébé